[موسيقى]
دعونا نتذكر باننا لا نعامل بوحشيه لاننا
محمدون لا نعامل بوحشيه لاننا منهجيون لا
نعامل بوحشيه لاننا مسلمون لا نعامل
بوحشيه لاننا كاثوليكيون نعامل بوحشيه
لاننا السود في امريكا
[موسيقى]
انني اتذكر كلمات امي في تلك اللحظات
استيقظوا استيقظ المنزل يحترق ويجب ان
نهرب اعترق المنزل تماما واستحال رمادا لم
تاتي سياره الاطفاء وصبنا بالخروف
[موسيقى]
عائلتك غادرت امها وانت تبلغ السنه تقريبا
كنت بعمر السنه ولما رحلوا حسنا بحسب ما
فهمت فان جماعه الكوكلوكس كلان احرقت احد
منازلهم في امها لا يمكنك النظر الى ذلك
بتسامح ايمكنك ذلك هذا غير صحيح لانه على
الرغم من ان ذلك حدث في امها ثم عندما
انتقلنا الى لانس في ميتشيغان تحرق منزلنا
مره اخرى والدي قتل على يد الكوك لوكس
كلانو
وبالاحرى تم دفع
عجلات ترامواي
[موسيقى]
كنت في السجن سابقا ولا اخجل من ذلك لم
يعد بامكانك استخدام ذلك فوق راسي
[موسيقى]
كنت في السجن كنت المشاكسا جدا مجرما
ارتجاعيا جاهلا غير مثقف واي صفات سلبيه
اخرى يمكنك تصورها في شخص ما الى حين سماع
تعاليم المبجل محمد
[موسيقى]
من الامريكيين الافارقه قال ساعبر علنا
عما كنا نفكر به
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اشك انه اراد اشتباك 500 شخص
لكنه قدم صوره عن الاسلام الذي يتواصل مع
الناس الذين يتفقون معه
كان ملكا على اولئك الذين لا ملك لهم
انها شهره اسلافي لقد سلبت منهم عندما
جاءوا الى امريكا واصبحوا عبيدا ثم منحوا
شهره اسيادهم التي رفضوها اتقصدوا انك لن
تخبرني ما هي شهره والدك المفترضه او
الشهره المهداه لكم لن اقولها ابدا مهما
حصل
[موسيقى]
اتهم الرجل الابيض والنساء والرجال في
هيئه المحلفين بكونهم اخطر المجرمين على
وجه الارض
[موسيقى]
هدف الدكتور مارتن لوثر كينج هو حث الزنوج
على مسامحه الناس الذين جزروا فينا منذ
400 سنه بالهدهده لهم للنوم وجعلهم ينسون
ما اصابهم بسبب البيض
[موسيقى]
لقد تكلم علنا وليس وراء الابواب المنصده
لقد تحدى امريكا من اجلنا
[موسيقى]
كانوا ضحايا رصاصات الشرطه ولا يمكنك سوق
الضحيه الى المحكمه بصفته مجرما والشرطه
هي من كان يجدر بها النسول للمحاكمه
[موسيقى]
بغي ان يكون الرجل الابيض شاكرا لان الرب
منح المبجل اليج محمد السيطره على اتباعه
الذين ينصحهم بالهدوء والرصانه والاجتماع
والاستسلام للرب هذا يفسر كل شيء هذه
المره سندافع عن انفسنا بانفسنا لا نحتاج
احدا اليوم كي يتحدى بسنا ويقاتل لاجلنا
[موسيقى]
ظهر رجل اخر يدعى كندي مندفع من اجل
الرئاسه اخبر الزنوج بكل ما سيقوم به من
اجلهم ان صوتوا له وقد صوت له بنسبه 80%
وها هو في منصبه الان منذ ثلاث سنوات وما
زالت المشكله قائمه
[موسيقى]
هذا التصريح هو من القائد اليجا محمد
المفوض مالكم شباز الذي القى خطابا في
لقاء شعبي في مركز منهات في نيويورك لم
يتحدث باسم المسلمين عندما ادنى بتعليقات
تتعلق بوفاه الرئيس جون كندي بل تحدث
باسمه وليس باسم المسلمين عامه
[موسيقى]
عندما يؤدي الشخص الحج هناك طقوس محدده
عليه اتباعها يجدر بالجميع الارتداء
بالطريقه البسيطه ذاتها
وهكذا لا يمكنك تمييز اي شخص اثناء الحج
وفقا لوضعه او وفقا لجذوره الوطنيه انه
اثبات على الاخوه في هذا المكان
الجميع كان متمازجا
واعتقد انه كان لذلك تاثير كبير
انقر على
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
المستقلين لا يسمون انفسهم بالبيض
ينظرون الى انفسهم كبشر وكجزء من العائله
الانسانيه
وبناء عليه ينظرون الى جميع الفصائل
العائله الانسانيه الاخرى بصفتهم جزءا من
العائله ذاتها
اذا قلت ان كان الاسلام قد فعل ذلك بهم
ربما البيض في امريكا قد يدرسون الاسلام
ربما يكون لذلك التاثير نفسه عليه
[موسيقى]
لما يهددون حياتك اولا لانهم خائفون من ان
افضح حقيقتهم لكن السبب الحقيقي هو ان
اليجا محمد قائد التحرك هو اب لثمانيه
اولاد من ست فتيات مراهقات ست فتيات
مراهقات كنا يعملن كسكراته
[موسيقى]
كان الامر جديا اروع امر جديد واتهام
المضجل الي محمد بهذه الامور كان كما لو
انك تدعو نهايه لحياتك هذا يعني ان احدا
ما قد يقتلك من امه الاسلام اجل ربما انا
رجل ميت الان
[موسيقى]
لماذا يقال اننا نكره البيت لا نحن لا
نكره احدا نحب شعبنا لدرجه انهم يعتقدون
اننا نكره من يعامله بظلم